what's going on people today I'm going
to explain every devil and Chainsaw man
that was created from the fear of
animals this video here will break down
the abilities and personality of all
animal devils and along the way we'll be
avoiding Major Spoilers although there
will sometimes be background info from
the manga that we need to talk about
finally before we get into it be sure to
hit that sub button if you want to see
more chainsaw man content like this and
I'd appreciate if you dropped a like as
well as it does help out the channel
okay so starting off with Bucky the
chicken devil this one was introduced in
chapter 98 and he is by far the weakest
devil in the whole video since chickens
are the most widely consumed animals on
the planet there are very few people who
are actually afraid of them and because
of that Bucky genuinely has no power
that's why when he first appeared he was
just the harmless-class pad of a
Japanese high school as the teacher knew
that he didn't pose a threat to any of
the students one thing that caught my
attention about Bucky straight away was
the fact that he was intelligent because
not only is he able to speak but he was
smart enough to come up with jokes and
remember the names of individual kids
prior to this it was implied that only
the stronger Devils could be expected to
have this level of brains whereas the
truly weak Devils weren't on the same
level however Bucky proved that this
wasn't always the case and for three
months he integrated into the class and
became loved by almost everyone during
that time he never tried to run away
since he knew that a stray dog or cat
could easily kill him so being in the
classroom was actually safer than the
outside world in terms of design the
most noticeable thing about Bucky is
that he's The Headless Chicken which is
likely a direct reference to Mike the
Headless Chicken who was a famous
rooster from America that surprisingly
survived for 18 months after being
decapitated Mike became so well known
that he taught across the country with
people paying money to get a look at him
and I think this plays into why Bucky
wears a bow tie because generally
speaking bow ties can be associated with
animals who are being put on show final
thing to mention about the chicken devil
is that he was self-aware to the point
where he refused to eat fried chicken
and he also expressed the fear of being
eaten himself next up we have princi the
spider devil who's a hunter working for
the Japanese government alongside denji
power and the rest of special division
IV considering that fear of spiders is a
relatively common phobia princey is
shown to be a strong Devil with some
unique abilities including the power to
teleport other people on her face she
has a zip running down the center and
when she wants to bring someone to her
location all she has to do is unzip her
body enabling them to emerge from the
gaping hole this power seems to work
regardless of the distance between
princy and the person being teleported
although from what we've seen can only
be done if both parties want it to
happen being the spider devil she
understandably has eight legs with sharp
points on the end and she can use them
to hang upside down from the ceiling
chop the heads of zombies in one go or
stab her Target from multiple angles on
top of that she can seemingly become
intangible sort of like mirio from my
hero Academia but this is something
she's only done one time as of making
this video this permeation means princy
can hide underground so that no one
knows she's there and when she's ready
she can quickly jump out and launch a
surprise attack last thing to say about
this character is that in chapter 34
Captain kushibe implied that she has
another form that looks more like a
devil but normally Prince he chooses to
look like this given that she's friendly
towards humans following this we have
the bat devil who was brilliantly
brought to life in the anime and his
personality made him one of denji's most
memorable villains like all Devils he
needs to drink blood to regenerate
himself but what makes the bat special
is that he had an almost encyclopedic
knowledge of what tastes the best for
example we learned from him that the
blood of pregnant women makes a nice
dessert whereas the blood of other
Devils is probably the worst thing you
can drink his fascination with all the
different flavors is directly connected
to the fact that he is a bad considering
that vampire bats are known to feed on
the blood of other animals and of course
the ultimate vampire Dracula could turn
into one because of this blood sucking
is a fear that humans associate with
bats which is why the bat devil acts the
way he does at some point this led to
him forming a romantic relationship with
the leech devil who's another devil
connected to blood sucking and together
they had the dream of eating every human
on the planet before that could happen
though the bat devil went into hiding
after one of his arms was chopped off by
a devil Hunter hence why he blackmailed
power to bring him someone to drink
throughout this off we saw that the bat
was extremely ruthless willing to
sacrifice humans animals and even his
own kind as long as it served his own
agenda after them regenerating back to
full strength he showed off a ton of
abilities including his mouth cannon
that blasted enough air to shatter a
whole building this power in particular
was inspired by bats in real life who
used echolocation to navigate themselves
through dark environments additionally
he has wing things that enable him to
fly through the sky at high speeds and
the bad sense of smell seemed to be even
stronger than the blood devil as he
could easily smell humans who were miles
away now after Dengue killed this devil
something pretty interesting happened
but in order to explain it we need to
discuss some background info from the
manga to put it simply in this world as
long as people still fear something then
a devil representing that thing will
always be born again what this means is
that when the devil is killed on earth
like the bat devil was then his spirit
will be reincarnated down in hell with
no memories from his previous life in
that way the devil gains a whole new
personality and if it ever returns to
earth and it can end up acting
drastically different from what it used
to be when it comes to the bat devil
this was one of those cases because when
he naturally reappeared after denji
killed him he became a brainless Savage
who couldn't talk and whose only
Instinct was to kill whoever happened to
be in front of him anyway switching over
to the octopus devil this animal has a
contract with Yoshida who's a private
devil Hunter and high school student
during his appearances so far Yoshida
has proven to be highly skilled in
combat and is able to incorporate devil
Powers into his fighting style for
instance in chapter 61 he strategically
summoned the octopus Devils just before
he took a huge hit and then after he was
thrown backwards its massive tentacles
were there to protect him following that
the devil sprayed large amounts of ink
which covered the room in darkness
giving ashita the chance to briefly
sneak through the Shadows undetected
against most enemies this would give him
the advantage especially since he can
then summon multiple giant tentacles at
the same time these tentacles can be
used to effortlessly deal with large
crowds or they can be used to restrain
someone and teleport them to a different
location something we see Yoshida do in
chapter 110 in order to summon the
octopus though he needs to make a hand
symbol by Crossing his two fingers
together similar to how certain other
Devils require hand gestures to be
summoned as well Additionally the
octopus devil is independent enough to
fight on yoshida's behalf while he takes
a break and he even sometimes uses it to
scan the nearby area for him so that he
knows exactly who's nearby now the first
and only fiend on this list is the shark
fiend also known as beam and just like
every other fiend he's a devil living
inside the corpse of a human as far as
his appearance goes he normally has a
shark snout poking out the front of his
face but the thing that makes him
different from most fiends is that if he
wants he can fully transform into a
devil in this devil form his whole body
turns into a shark with six eyes however
he does have the option to just
partially transform his head from the
moment he was introduced it was obvious
that beam has a history with Vegeta as
the fiend constantly referred to him as
Lord chainsaw and in chapter 49 he
recounts in detail how the chainsaw
devil used to fight back in the day his
respect for Batista is so high that he
puts his life on the line multiple times
to protect Angie even if that means
taking point-blank attacks from powerful
devils and he also happily does anything
Genji asked him to because he's a fiend
beam strength is weaker than what it
used to be in his prime but despite that
he still possesses his main ability
which is permeation with permeation the
shark devil can swim through any surface
including surfing across buildings
jumping through walls or swimming
underground this level of intangibility
is like a more useful version of what
Prince he can do and it enables beam to
easily Escape when he's in danger the
problem with disability though is that
if the sharp fiend is carrying someone
else he doesn't have the power to make
them intangible as well so in that
situation he's not able to fully pass
through walls or do anything like that
as long as he's holding the other person
moving on to the snake devil this one
for me has got to be one of the most
disturbing looking devils in the whole
series besides having the long gigantic
snake body which is to be expected what
makes it so unsettling is that its mouth
is made from Human arms topped off with
these tiny teeth that kind of resemble
the xenomores from the alien franchise
when the author of Chainsaw man Fujimoto
was in the concept stage he initially
drew the snake devil to be a lot less
intimidating but given that it's meant
to be such a menacing threat it makes
sense why the horror was cranked up for
the final thing regarding the snake's
potential so far the only humanists made
a contract with this saw Atari and she's
been able to use his power in a few
different ways for example in chapter 25
she used his giant mouth to completely
swallow another strong devil comparable
to how in real life certain snakes are
able to swallow large animals like
crocodiles or even cows by eating
another devil saw Atari and the snake
then gain a degree of control over it
and in future battles the snake can
vomit it back out and make it fight for
them another thing about the snake is
that although it's incredibly fast it's
not so fast that a skilled devil Hunter
won't be able to avoid it next in line
we have the leech devil who was briefly
mentioned earlier in the video and just
like her boyfriend she ended up getting
brutally torn apart by the public safety
devil Hunters on her introduction she
had a huge body that towered over denji
completely and was strong enough to
sever his arm without even really trying
just like the bat she had an inherent
hatred for all humans on Earth but
interestingly she was willing to let her
boyfriend's killer Go free just because
he had a good looking face to me this
shows that she clearly wasn't on the
same level when it came to his ruthless
mindset considering that he did this to
power just because he gave him some bad
blood on that topic the leech devil also
didn't mind consuming denji's hybrid
blood even though the bat devil acted
like it was the most disgusting thing
he'd ever had showing that you know
despite both being based of
blood-sucking creatures their senses of
taste might not be as similar as we
expect anyway while it's true that we
didn't get to see the leech devil fight
for very long it's fair to say that
denji was almost able to match her even
when he couldn't transform into chainsaw
man if he'd been able to regenerate then
I'm fairly certain he would have ripped
out to shreds but in his human form she
was eventually able to spear him using
our tongue luckily for denji Aki had
been tracking his movements and showed
up at the exact right time to save him
along with the fox devil the fox is by
far the most popular devil among Japan's
Public Safety Hunters with Aki arai and
several others forming contracts with
her over the years by making this
special gesture and aiming at the Target
within the hall Hunters can some the
devil to their location as long as they
say the word Khan which is Japanese
equivalent to saying woof but
specifically for foxes however not
everyone with a contract can use the
full extent of its abilities like this
as the devil only allows Attractive
people to summon her head what that
means is that number one she thinks Aki
is good looking which is fair enough and
number two just like the leash these
Devils can be just as superficial as
humans in my opinion this is because all
devils are created from one human
emotion which is fear so it makes sense
that other human traits like romance and
favoritism would occasionally manifest
themselves whatever the reason the fox
Devil's drawer is super powerful as it
was able to crush the leech Devil's body
in a single bite and Trump through a
building without much trouble when it
comes to the other devil Hunters who
aren't as good looking as this the fox
is poor is the most useful body part
since it can be used to attack incoming
enemies whether it's one person or an
entire group similar to the snake devil
though the poor isn't so fast that it's
unavoidable because on more than one
occasion enemies have been able to dodge
this attack completely in terms of
Design This devil has one of the best in
the series taking on the appearance of a
giant white fox with multiple red eyes
spread across both her head and her paws
prior to the anime coming out most of
the fan art usually gave her orange fur
instead of white which personally I
think looked even better but regardless
either color still works perfectly fine
finally to wrap this video up we have
five Devils that we know virtually
nothing about besides their physical
appearance and those are the fish devil
sea cucumber devil cockroach devil
mantis devil and pig devil the fish
devil first appeared in episode 5 of the
anime having already been defeated by
Aki and its corpse was surrounded by
what looked like a bunch of fish eggs
its main body weirdly had two tails and
six inset looking legs but it's possible
this appearance might be the result of
it receiving a power up from the gun
devil the sea cucumber devil was another
underwater creature that manifested in
the anime and before power smashed it to
Pieces there was the skull and dozens of
decomposing fingers poking out of its
fleshy body considering that most
cucumbers tip typically live deep in the
sea this design could be referring to
humans over the years who have died in
the ocean and whose bodies have never
been recovered because it seems like a
good reason why these body parts would
be so highly integrated into its
appearance the Cockroach devil is next
up and this one is basically a highly
intelligent Kaiju generally speaking
roaches are associated with being
resilient insects that can survive
almost anything including a nuclear war
and regardless of whether that's
actually true it's still something that
a lot of people believe for that reason
it shouldn't be a surprise that the
Cockroach devil had thick layers of bone
protecting his body and his high level
of intelligence was directly comparable
to the bad devil as an example they both
openly questioned why change the man
would side with humans instead of devils
and they each gave density a test to see
how much of a hero he really is in the
bat Devil's case he threw a car with
someone inside only to realize that
chainsaw man didn't care about this
guy's life at all similarly the
Cockroach devil gave him the option to
save a young student with a bright
future or a car full of old men but
again okay so man didn't care about
either of them and instead he
prioritized saving a nearby cat moving
on in chapter 41 the pig devil made its
first and only appearance of the series
and the most notable thing about it is
that before Public Safety arrived the
devil had eaten a private devil Hunter
the hunter in question had his legs
ripped off but was somehow still able to
survive inside the pig's guts forcing a
reluctant Aki to put him out of his
misery lastly the praying mantis devil
has also only made one single appearance
in the manga showing up in chapter 91
after being summoned by two devil
Hunters by clasping their hands together
the matches his leg burst out of the
ground and was used to slice a nearby
devil although the agents were still
immediately killed by that devil seconds
later
with that said that completes our list
of all animal Devils that have appeared
in chainsaw man so far and if you
enjoyed this video then be sure to drop
a like and hit that sub button so you
don't miss future videos like this until
the next one peace out